what happened when you went to the
country music awards i'm talking about
back in
2016 and you performed with beyonce
i don't know whether it was because of
your country fans who felt you had
betrayed them or
she wasn't country i remember it was
just a big [ __ ] brouhaha that you
showed up with beyonce
like it like criticized for that right
um
you know it was just a weird vibe in
that building we hadn't done
anything uh country award shows or
anything
since the controversy let me just say
the week we worked with beyonce
is the single greatest working week of
my professional life it was
awesome to watch her world to see how
she does stuff
it's she's a perfectionist and to see
the power she has as a female
and a black female is incredible and i
guess they can rate those
shows now by the 15 minutes it's the
highest rated 15 minutes in cma history
and then they start getting you know
racist [ __ ]
bombarding their website with comments
and emails and whatever
and so they take her down they took our
performance down
and caved to that [ __ ] and then
they i guess got so much bad press for
doing that
within 24 hours they put it back up
again just cowards it's just
crazy she just gave you your greatest
ratings
that you've ever gotten how dare you
take her song off
it was [ __ ] kidding me i knew none of
that
would you ever perform at the country
music awards again or have you just had
it
no i mean we i said i would never after
2003
but then when beyonce calls you're like
okay maybe just this one time
one last time do you get nervous i'll
only do it with beyonce
do you get nervous when you have to
perform with someone like beyonce
or are you just so seasoned at all this
that like nothing kind of throws you
i mean i i don't know about nervous i
was excited i mean lemonade i listened
to lemonade
at least one i mean the full album at
least once a day
we listened to it every day on tour um i
watched the lemonade visual album
over a hundred times she's just the
consummate professional and you just
don't want to let b
down that was all i was thinking is uh
just
yeah do it right do it right
you